here it's X X and X square root of 2 so
these angles here are the 45-degree
angles okay and what you can think of is
you can think of this as a square that's
been cut in half on the diagonal so if
you were to look at this originally all
these sides would be ax and if you do
the Pythagorean theorem a squared plus B
squared equals C squared you'll find
that the hypotenuse is whatever the leg
is times the square root of 2 and just
for reference square root of 2 is about
1.4 so it's just like when you try to
put something in a box if you try to put
it this way it doesn't fit if you try to
put it this way it doesn't fit if you
put it on the diagonal though often
times it'll fit because this is actually
1.4 times longer so this is the ratio
you want to remember X X and X square
root of 2 4 45-45-90 triangles so let's
look at some examples say this one over
here they give us the leg length is X so
what would be this side length right
here
well it'll also be 3 because this is an
isosceles triangle the base angles are
congruent so these sides these legs are
going to be congruent but if we multiply
by the square root of 2 now we find the
hypotenuse 3 square root of 2 so it's
1.4 times longer than one of these side
lengths ok now in this one they're
giving us the hypotenuse 4 square root
of 2 so what we're going to do to go
from the hypotenuse to the leg we have
to divide by the square root of 2 so
what's 4 square root of 2 divided by
square root of 2 well you can see that's
going to be 4 and because this is
isosceles both of these are going to be
congruent so this is going to be 4 ok
last example here we've got a 45-45-90
they're giving us the hypotenuse is 10
how do we go from the hypotenuse back to
one of the legs well what we're going to
have to do is divide by the square root
of 2 but we don't want the radical in
the denominator so what do we do to get
rid of the radical in the denominator we
rationalize by multiplying by square
root of 2 over square root of 2 this way
square root of 2 times square root of 2
gives a square root of 4 which is 2
and we get 10 times the square root of 2
the 10 in the 2 we can reduce so that's
going to be 5 square root of 2 and both
of these legs will be the same
so 5 roots square root of 2 5 square
root of 2 so take a look at my other
video about the 30-60-90 special right
triangle and I'll see you in the next
video